[Music]
it's presidents week here on the Rubin
report working with learn liberty to
bring you five shows in five days on
five different presidents of the United
States and joining me today is professor
of history and economics at San Jose
State University and author of the book
emancipating the slaves enslaving
freemen a history of the American Civil
War Jeffery Rogers Hummel
welcome to the Rubin report it's a
pleasure to be on the ribbon report we
have already just in a few minutes we've
been sitting here we talked about almost
every other present right now I guess
we're gonna have to get the Lincoln guy
yes definitely let's do it so first off
the obvious question was he actually a
vampire hunter I doubt it it's not a
show that I watched was it a movie I
forget it was a movie I thought it was a
documentary but not all right there's a
lot I want to talk to you now it was
obvious when we were selecting our five
presidents to do this week we wanted to
do some of it some of the big ones and
some smaller ones and hopefully we'll do
this for many years to come and get to
everybody but Lincoln was the one I was
like alright we got to do it because I
think if you polled most Americans they
always say that Lincoln is their
favorite right I think probably George
Washington comes in second but I think
Lincoln is the big one so I want to do a
little bit on his bio than I want to do
obviously on the political stuff and
Civil War in freeing the slaves and I
want to talk about some of the
interesting criticisms that you have of
him in this book but first let's just
start a little bit about childhood where
should we start well Lincoln was born in
Kentucky 1809 and grew up in a in a very
poor frontier household his mother died
when he was very young I was partly
raised by a by a stepmother they moved
to Indiana and basically he educated
himself and and it was a humble
background yeah as he would have as he
as he described it himself how was that
possible to educate himself back then I
mean was he just grabbed
he was just grabbing books and reading
them at every opportunity he could get
and yeah that's basic thats basically
the story yeah do we know anything about
his further education as he got a little
bit older uh I don't know anything about
his further education I don't think he
was university educated he obviously
went on to get a law degree but in those
days getting a law degree was you
clerked under a lawyer and then you hung
out your shingle right so as far as
formal education is concerned he didn't
have very much of that yeah was his
really ambition at first to be a lawyer
I don't know whether he had a real
ambition at first I mean you know he he
he he had a lot of other kinds of more
frontier oriented jobs right that's how
he got the nickname the Railsplitter
working on the rivers and and those
sorts of things and so I think he just
sort of fell into law yeah so he's a lot
but eventually I mean eventually
politics became his passion yeah so he's
a lawyer and then politics became his
passion yes I would say those two are
interrelated because remember at that
time many of your politicians if not
most of your politicians where either
came through the military or through the
profession of law yeah
was there a seminal moment for him that
he realized this is when and why I have
to get into politics uh no I don't think
so I don't think so
you know it's like life happens yeah and
opportunities open and you take
advantage of them yeah and you know he
a legal profession in Illinois and then
he was elected to the Illinois
legislature eventually elected to the
House of Representatives for a short
time and and became very prominent in
the Illinois Whig party
yeah what were his politics like in time
and what was the Whig party like okay
well this is one of the if you look at
the two parties ideologically at that
time it was the Whigs versus the
Democrats the Whigs were the end of
interventionist party the Whigs were in
favor of high protective tariffs they
were in favor of spending a lot of money
government money on internal
improvements what we call infrastructure
today and they were in favor of a
nationally chartered bank and a lot of
these policies were the outgrowth of one
of the most prominent Whig leaders Henry
Clay and what he termed his American
system whereas by this time the
Democratic Party had become the party of
laissez faire low tariffs getting rid of
the National Bank and in fact actually
trying to divorce government from any
relationship with banks and at least
trying to keep the federal government
out of funding internal improvements
yeah that that's very interesting to me
because in a modern sense that seems to
be a bit of a reversal right where we're
at right now
right was was Lincoln really in line
with oh yeah he's I mean he really
admired Henry Clay Henry Clay what was
his hero and he he supported all those
policies down the line when he was in
the state legislature in Illinois he was
crucial in passing a very expensive
internal improvements program in
Illinois that subsequently almost drove
the state into bankruptcy
financing of canals and and railroads
yeah so fiscally at the time he was he
was spending a lot and did the the
infrastructure deal actually makes sense
well I know in other words in other
words if if what happened is that the
states went through sort of two phases
in terms of infrastructure the first
phase was Canal building and the second
phase was railroads these are often
referred to as phases of the
transportation revolution during that
period the canal building orgy was
actually set off by New York building
the Erie Canal which is one of the few
examples of a socialist enterprise that
actually made a profit and so this
inspired a lot of other states to build
canals almost all of which lost money
and created financial problems for the
states that built them which suggests
that they were not economically
justified yeah and then as a result of
the states losing so much money on the
canals initially they were heavily
involved in railroads and they continued
to subsidize the railroads but at least
by the 1840s and 1850s they weren't
owning outright the railroads the way
they had owned outright the canals and
therefore either there was a little bit
too much railroad expansion subsidized
by the government but it wasn't as
significant as the problems created by
the canal building interesting because
this is a part of Lincoln that I don't
you know we mostly think about the Civil
War right and freeing the slaves but the
economic part is sort of interesting
what do you think his sort of overriding
economic policy was because it sounds
like it was a it was a lot of he carried
this policy into the presidency the
first subsidized transcontinental
railroads were during Lincoln's
administration during the Civil War and
that resulted in many other
Transcontinental's and being subsidized
by the national government
and a whole bunch of pork-barrel
legislation in the in the post-civil war
period and a lot of scandals corruption
involved as well yeah so so so his
economic views continued throughout his
entire career and these were this was
the main dividing line between the two
policies between the two political
parties because up until the Civil War
both political parties tied to straddle
the issue of slavery so they would both
be national parties so they tried to
keep it out as best they could out of
the political arena yeah when did he
start talking about slavery really I
mean when he was in the Illinois
legislature no he doesn't really start
talking about slavery he he he had a
visceral dislike of slavery from his
youth but he didn't really start talking
about slavery until after the
kansas-nebraska act and slavery becomes
a prominent issue and it causes the
death of the Whig party mm-hmm
and the collapse of the of the Whig
party yeah can you explain that a little
bit more why why that actually yeah yeah
well see both parties initially try to
straddle the slavery issue but as as it
evolves over time the Whig party being
more interventionist tends to be
stronger in New England whereas the
Democratic Party tending to be
non-interventionist tends to be stronger
in the south and the west and so the
both parties feel the strain between
northern and southern democrats northern
and southern Whigs but the Whig party is
actually blown apart by that strain
after the kansas-nebraska Act and one
issue that causes the demise of the Whig
party
is slavery so you have the split between
northern Whigs and southern Whigs and
then also another issue that comes to
the fore during that period is
immigration
there is a nativist movement that some
Whigs end up embracing and that also is
a plays a role in the demise of the Whig
party yeah
what was his policy well actually
Lincoln was fairly good on that I mean
he in other words there was a debate
within the council's of the Republican
Party about you know between those who
were more nativist and those who were
less nativist and Lincoln was definitely
on the side of the one he didn't want he
didn't want the Republican Party to be
him to take a platform stand on nativism
opposing immigration or actually they
they they weren't proposing restrictions
on immigration so much as restrictions
on acquiring citizenship so when the
Whig Party fell apart and then basically
the remnants became the Republican Party
what well what was that like what like
where the day literally just well
actually the people or a man well well
inissia initially the Republican Party
is a coalition of anti-slavery Whigs
and anti-slavery Democrats so it it's
exclusively a sectional party it's
almost exclusively so just to be really
clear on that though so the Republican
Party actually was the original
anti-slavery party it was taking from
both sides and was right taking now we
need to be clear about this term
anti-slavery because being anti-slavery
was a was a broad tent at one extreme
were the abolitionists and at least in
America the term abolitionist refers to
anti-slavery advocates who favor
immediate emancipation of all slaves and
full political rights for all African
Americans
so there's a whole range of anti-slavery
positions and so the Republican Party
the abolitionists are always a minority
and the Republican Party succeeds where
the abolitionists don't succeed by
reducing anti-slavery to its lowest
common denominator essentially one issue
which is opposing the spread of slavery
into the territories and so you have and
again the kansas-nebraska act in which
in which Kansas and Nebraska were opened
to slavery
in violation of the Missouri Compromise
is what sort of inspires this concern
among anti-slavery northerners so just
just to be clear at the beginning of the
Civil War there are a lot of Democrats
involved in former Democrats involved in
the Republican Party Lincoln's Secretary
of State Salman Chase is a former
Democrat several Republican governors
and Senate are me yet Republican
senators and governors are former
Republicans so in Lincoln's election the
Republican Party has to sort of straddle
these economic issues to keep both sides
of the coalition together where did he
fall when he was running for president
where did he fall on that scale of
abolitionists to what what would you
call he was a would you call that other
group they were sort of well they're
just they're just anti-slavery yeah and
but what that approach that they had
what would you repeal was that pragmatic
or what did they base it
well gradualist pragmatic basically
again this is where Lincoln follows
Henry Clay Henry Clay was a favor it was
in favor of colonization in other words
not just having a plan of perhaps
compensated emancipation in which freed
slaves
are moved to back to Africa and Lincoln
was a big advocate of colonization and
in fact he continues to pursue
colonization even after the outbreak of
the Civil War by the end of the Civil
War he's probably given up on that but
during the Civil War he sponsored one
disastrous attempt at colonization in
Haiti that it just didn't yeah what
happened well what happened is that
there they got the I'm a little bit hazy
on the details but but some land was
acquired in Haiti and they got some
african-americans who agreed to move
there and then it was not just
economically unviable but does have
problems with disease and so the whole
colony collapsed in other words he
wanted to do he wanted to push in in
Latin America something similar to
Liberia in in Africa which also was also
a colonization scheme set up by the
American Colonization Society of which
Henry Clay was a participant right so
there's a couple interesting things
there so you referenced that the Whig
party itself had a sort of internal
conflict between their northern
representatives that would be someone
like Abraham Lincoln and their southern
if you were a local representative in
the legislature in Illinois did it ever
come up to talk about I mean why would
slavery even really it was only within
the national discussion right like was
it something that people were actually
voting on in anyway not at the state
level now yeah there it's hard to think
of party politics in a 20-18 lens
without everything being right national
and everybody affected by every little
thing yeah yeah no the only sense in
which it was the only sense in which the
state you got involved at the state
level was with respect to the Fugitive
Slave Law so if you look at the history
of slavery there's always this ten
in between free states and slave states
even at the Constitutional Convention
but it is usually kept below the surface
except during these instances where it
where it erupts and then it's resolved
so you first have Missouri coming in as
a slave state which leads to the
Missouri Compromise and then things calm
down and then you have the tariff issue
which is partially driven by South
Carolina's slave and then you have
things calming down with the annexation
of Texas and California coming in as a
state slavery becomes a big issue again
and it's partially calmed down by the
compromise of 1850 and then after that
you have the kansas-nebraska Act and
then then there's no coming it down
anymore and the compromise of 1850 is
responsible part of the part of what
southerners got out of the compromise of
1850 or more precisely slaveholders was
the slave was the Fugitive Slave Act of
1850 now one of the one of the
constitutional deals I mean right in the
Constitution there's a fugitive slave
provision in which it's the obligation
of free states to return runaway slaves
and the Washington administration
actually passed the first Fugitive Slave
Act but the Fugitive Slave Act of 1850
was one of the most draconian laws that
Congress ever enacted yeah
and in other words it set up a
bureaucracy of commissioners who would
hear cases of fugitive slaves they got
$5.00 if they decided that that the
person wasn't a slave and $10 if they
decided it was a slave right so you're
right they
the slave had no right to represent
gestation a jury trial no right to
testify the legisla and the the
commissioners could require the
cooperation of individuals to apprehend
Runaways and if you violated that you
could face a jail sentence $1,000 fine
$1,000 civil penalties for each escaped
slave so it was pretty so many of your
northern states began have before this
but began after this passing what were
called personal liberty laws trying to
make sure that state officials did not
participate in the apprehension and
return of Runaways and so that's that's
that's the that's the big slavery issue
in northern states yeah it sounds like
such a crazy thing because they were
incentivizing the north right yeah that
may not have wanted to send the slaves
back they were literally financially
incentivizing and then as you're saying
there were other people there were just
citizens that were going out there right
and it also also also made it easier to
engage in kidnapping free blacks yeah
bringing them south who was fighting
this the most I mean I would imagine
there must have been some states rights
people in the North that maybe you
didn't even care about slavery per se
but must have said you can't tell yeah
well this this is this is one of the
things after the compromise of 1850 that
brings slavery starts pushing it to the
forefront and of course this is when
Kelly Elliot Uncle Tom's Cabin
Henry beat what's her first name I'm
drawing a blank Harriet Beecher Stowe
writes Uncle Tom's Cabin which becomes a
best-seller and it's about the Fugitive
Slave issues so it sensitizes a lot of
northerners to the Fugitive Slave
question and so Illinois does
pass a personal liberty law because
Southern Illinois is actually settled by
from the southern the eastern southern
states but some of your other states
like Pennsylvania and states further
north
do pass personal liberty laws yeah as a
result of either before the Fugitive
Slave Act or after the Fugitive Slave
Act so before we get directly into the
presidency and the warriors there
anything else we need to know about
Lincoln's politics at the time or what
else was influencing him besides
obviously there were states rights
issues there was obviously the slavery
issue it was there anything else that we
think of as really the moments that kind
of shaped him before the president I
think I think we I think we've covered
the important issues the big ones okay
so he runs for president what what do we
need to know about that platform well as
I say it tries to paper over the
difference between former Democrats and
former Whigs it has a it has a plank
about about the tariff that can be
interpreted differently but the primary
plank is is opposition to the spread of
slavery into anymore territories and
what's interesting about that plank is
that it's essentially that plank has
essentially been declared
unconstitutional by the Supreme Court in
the Dred Scott decision
in the Dred Scott decision the Supreme
Court says that the the territories are
the common property of both northerners
and southerners and therefore the
national government cannot restrict the
property rights of southerners when they
move into the territories by preventing
them from bringing their slaves so that
so you have a you have a platform plank
that was that was literally on
Constitution
declared unconstitutional I mean most
Supreme Court most legal scholars today
think it was a very bad decision but yes
it was had been declared
unconstitutional what do we need to know
about the the tenor of the political
infighting at that time you know these
days everyone always says never
everything's never been worse everyone's
meaner than never before and you know
Trump's tweeting this and all that but
there were some pretty serious fighting
and yeah yeah those kinds of claims are
exaggerated I mean you you can find
campaign rhetoric and campaign
literature that if not vicious verges on
being vicious throughout this the period
leading up to the Civil War I wouldn't
say that the Civil War or the 1860
election is particularly unique in that
respect but what happens is that you end
up having four candidates Lincoln as the
candidate of the Republican Party and
then the Democratic Party splits so you
have Stephen Douglas as the candidate of
the northern Democrats John Breckinridge
is the candidate of the southern
democrats and then some of your upper
tiers former southern Whigs form a
constitutional Union Party
so to oversimplify only a little it
becomes really two elections an election
between Lincoln and Douglas in the north
and an election between Breckinridge and
John Bell and the constitutional Union
Party in the south yeah so the next
obvious segue is the Lincoln Douglas
debate right that's now that's before
the 1860 election it was for that
election though no no no no this is
remember this is a time when senators
are still chosen by the state
legislature so that's one of the things
that makes a debate unique because it's
it's the 1858 Senate
election in Illinois the legislature is
going to choose who is going to be the
senator but the Republican candidate is
is Lincoln the Democratic candidate is
Douglas I didn't and then they go around
and have these debates at various
locations throughout Illinois that's
funny I mean I like that I know a lot
about this I had no idea that that
wasn't on the national scale because
they did run against each other just two
years later two years later and that's
it yes but this actually propels Lincoln
into the forefront of potential
candidates for the Republican nomination
in 1860 even though the legislature
chooses Douglas as Illinois senator so
when for I want you to explain what the
lincoln-douglas debates are and why
there's such a richness there but was
nothing like this even done before that
way everyone talks about it like it was
so revolutionary or we said yes we could
use it these days I wouldn't I wouldn't
go so far I say nothing like it but in
terms of how extensive it was and the
draw it was unprecedented
yeah can you explain the basic tenets of
sort of how it would work well basically
they they picked out various locations
in Illinois I forget the number of
debates and they would travel there and
then they would face off each other and
the big issue was slavery and Lincoln
his position was prohibiting slavery the
extension of slavery into the
territories Douglass's position he was
trying he was the Democratic Party
hadn't split so he was trying to
maintain the unity of the Democratic
Party so his position is known as
popular sovereignty and his view was
that we leave the territories open and
then let people in the territories
decide whether it
going to be a slave territory or a free
territory but that creates a certain
amount of ambiguity because when did
they get to decide did they only get to
decide at the time of statehood also if
they decide before statehood aren't they
violating the Dred Scott decision so so
that was but there was also a racial
element to the debates because you
brought up the issue of viciousness in
the campaigns the attempt is to paint
Lincoln as an advocate of racial
amalgamation because even in the north
despite the the northern states being
free states in most of the northern
states african-americans faced legal
disabilities and and significant social
discrimination so so at this time
Lincoln would make the distinction
between between a civil equality
political equality and social equality
and civil equality is being that means
being equal before the law political
equality would involve giving African
Americans the right to vote and then we
know what social equality is about so
his position at this time he did not
advocate political equality was not in
favor of giving African Americans the
right to vote but he was firmly in favor
of civil equality and that's where he
and Douglass differed what was that part
totally pragmatic in that he felt if he
said while I am for a it might have been
pragmatic but remember he he's a as I
said he was a he was in favor of
colonization mmm-hmm even if he even
when he began to entertain views of
political equality for pragmatic reasons
not
politically but for pragmatic reasons he
wasn't sure the country was ready in
other words he would use arguments which
I think are sincere that that that that
you know that the two races are not
going to be comfortable living together
and that it would be better off for
african-americans once free to move
elsewhere yeah now he eventually
eventually drops that and eventually by
the end of his life was favoring a
limited franchise for freed
african-americans in Louisiana so he
says his ideas are changing they're
progressing yeah yeah that's what's
interesting is that there is an
evolutionary which really we find out
really in the presidency did the
abolitionists basically hate him at that
point I mean did they think he was sort
of a sellout or that he just because he
was doing the pragmatic thing yes some
abolitionist did some abolitionist did
and so there was still there had been
before the creation of the Republican
Party there had been the Liberty Party
in the Free Soil party which were
slightly broader anti-slavery
coalition's but minor minor parties and
there still was a radical abolitionist
party that ran in 1860 but it garnered
very very few votes mm-hmm okay so we
started touching them the beginnings of
the election so basically four
candidates running right because it is
split in the the Democratic Party what
else do we have to know before he gets
elected that happens that's pretty much
it I mean he didn't win the popular vote
but even if you combined the vote of all
the other candidates he still would have
won the electoral college right
interesting so what was the beginning of
his presidency like well the beginning
of his presidency is dominated by the
secession of the deep south so soon
after he was inaugurated well after he's
elected the deep south succeeds with
South Carolina being the first state and
then you have the cotton States
seceding what's he been inaugurated that
was right after the that's incredible by
the way one interesting detail that a
lot of people are unaware of in South
Carolina's Ordinance of Secession and
they're the first state there that
they're the most firebrand of all the
secessionist in there Ordinance of
Secession they do not the the issue they
give the largest play to in terms of
justifying secession mmm-hmm
is not Lincoln's election but northern
failure to comply with the Fugitive
Slave Clause of the Constitution now
partially that's a rhetorical ploy
because I allow them to argue that the
northerners a had violated the
constitutional contract first but it
also reflects a deep concern about
fugitive slaves and and one of the one
of the points that I make in my book is
that I think most historians have
underestimated the economic significance
of the Fugitive Slave issue in terms of
bringing on secession and maybe we can
get to yeah no I I do want to get to
that so so so you have the deep south
seceding and they're seizing all of the
US military bases mm-hmm except for a
few that are holding out and the
prominent one that's holding out is Fort
Sumter in Charleston Harbor
so James Buchanan has to deal with this
he's the lame-duck president he tries to
reinforce Sumter and South Carolina
fires on the ship and so but the
garrison is still there when Lincoln it
becomes president so that's the big
issue that's dominating Lincoln's
presidency is what do you what do you do
about Fort Sumter and Lincoln you know
he's getting all kinds of advice some
people want him to try to back down on
the Republican position about slavery in
the territories
but he absolutely refuses to do so I
mean he's he has agreed to enforce the
Fugitive Slave Act as president so it's
this is the only anti-slavery issue and
he decides to hang on to it and some
want a more aggressive policy someone a
more passive policy basically Lincoln
essentially follows Buchanan's policy
although Buchanan gets a lot of good
criticism and what happens is well
Buchanan's policy being what being
trying to reinforce the fort but not
using military force to to hold on to
the fort gotcha all right so Lincoln
sends reinforcements and supplies to the
fort telling the South Carolina that
he's doing so by this time the
Confederacy is formed the Confederacy
fires on Fort Sumter right and and
that's the that's the 911 of the Civil
War it polarizes both sides it polarizes
northerners because there are up until
this time there are a lot of northerners
who say well we should let the South go
in peace many of them think well if we
let them go in peace they'll come back
and at the time of Lincoln's
inauguration there's still more slave
states in the Union than out of the
Union but Lincoln in responds to the
firing on Fort Sumter by calling out
troops and immediately Virginia North
Carolina Tennessee and Arkansas all
joined the Confederacy so it it it's the
great divide what with a stroke of the
pen he's he's doubled the size and the
material resources of the Confederacy
yeah what do we know about his thought
process at the time was he really ready
for the fallout that was going to happen
yes and now and then the escalation yeah
yes and now let me back up a little and
explain why he had to do this alright
why it was politically necessary to do
this many of your abolitionists
particularly William Lloyd Garrison is
one of my heroes who was advocated
immediate emancipation full political
rights for all African Americans he was
also a pacifist an anarchist a classical
liberal in favor of free trade free
labor this guy his opposition to slavery
a lot of the radical abolitionists
framed it as man stealing you know in
terms of property rights and he was also
in favor of northern secession from the
Union because he saw the Constitution as
a pro-slavery document he denounced the
Constitution publicly burned a copy and
on the masthead of his of his paper that
Liberator no union with slaveholders
graced it throughout from 1831 on up to
the Civil War and and this was true of
many of your most radical abolitionists
so basically what your abolitionists and
one of the reasons they were so
unpopular is because they were saying
you can't have anti-slavery and Union
and people are committed to the Union
right so they're not happy about the
Appalachian yeah the Republican Party by
reducing the anti-slavery issue to its
lowest common denominator in the
territories is telling the public you
can have a anti-slavery in Union mmm-hmm
all right well once the union's
threatened the Republican Party is going
to have to suppress secession or face
political oblivion and in fact even if
Stephen Douglas had been elected
president he's an old hard-line
Jacksonian if he had been elected
president and the South had still
seceded now that's not very likely but
if he had been elected president and the
south its seceded he probably would have
moved military force against the South
even faster than Lincoln mm-hmm
it's so interesting because I think one
of the themes as we do this whole week
is looking at these people through 2018
lens and when you hear that somebody
didn't want full rights for people but
wanted to free them or they couldn't
vote or some of the other issues you're
talking about and yet at the same time
you're saying but the abolitionists
actually weren't that popular right it's
like to give to view these people
through our lens today is is really it's
a very slippery slope because Lincoln
had to do some things that perhaps in
our lens now would have been viewed as
very unfair to the african-american
right yeah and there he was so okay so
the the war begins and he said he's a
new president at war
who is he getting advice from we're like
did he really understand how to okay
well yeah the other part of the answer
to your question is that Lincoln and
many of the Republicans and many
Northerners in general underestimated
the enthusiasm for secession on the part
of southerners they believed initially
believed that it was a southern elite of
slaveholders almost a conspiracy that
had brought about secession and that and
that's why they weren't prepared for the
extent of the resistance of southerners
once Lincoln
calls out troops yeah and so once he
calls out troops then then you have the
problem of managing the war so there was
really nothing he could have done at
that point even even if there were
voices even if he internally felt well
maybe we could just let them go or if
think he had voices around him that
we're saying uh you know sorry that
looks a seed it was too late really
right yeah but politically yeah alright
politically I mean by that time in the
north at least not it not in the deep
south but in the north
liberty and union have become mystically
identified as inseparable and and so
that's and in fact right this leads to
the question of a more basic question of
what caused the civil war right and
there's now a current trend to argue
that slavery caused the Civil War and
not only it caused the Civil War but it
was all about slavery and that in fact
slavery the entire history the Union up
until that point is all about slavery
you disagree I think that asking what
caused the Civil War is the wrong
question and even some of your new
abolitionists historians like Ken Stamp
and Eric Foner have pointed out that
they're really two separate questions
why does the south [ __ ] and why does
the North refuse to let the South go and
the answer to the first question is
definitely slavery I mean the evidence
is overwhelming for that there's
probably hardly any historical causal
explanation at that level of abstraction
for which the evidence is more
overwhelming so the South secedes in
order to protect slavery okay so that's
that ending slavery is not what
motivates the north yeah what motivates
the north is preserving the Union and in
fact Lincoln in the before the firing on
Fort Sumter endorses a original 13th
amendment which has not passed in which
he's still holding to the position of
opposing the extension of slavery in the
territories but this new amendment would
protect slavery in the existing slave
states and be unamended mm-hmm
in the early days of the war some of
your Union commanders were returning
runaway slaves so so so so the war from
the Union perspective the suppression of
secession is designed to preserve the
Union
and Lincoln even later says if he could
preserve the Union by freeing all the
slaves he'll do that if he could
preserve the Union by freeing some no no
the slaves he'll do that if he can
preserve the Union by freeing some and
leaving others enslaved he would do that
what was his real belief in the Union
based in did he did that he just truly
believed that we had to remain one
country otherwise we would be yeah
perpetual war is that yeah yeah yeah
yeah he thought that the dissolution of
the Union would lead to anarchy yeah
it's interesting now now one of the
things that's one of the things that's
interesting about historians is the the
even historians who don't seem to be
explicitly nationalists and the
nationalist bias with which they
approach that issue so for instance the
US had made several attempts to annex
Canada in the early history first during
the American Revolution then during the
war of 1812 and then between and after
those events by sponsoring the kinds of
revolutionary movements that brought
Texas into the Union all right if any of
those had succeeded historians would be
writing his historians would be writing
the history of North America as if this
was inevitable and any other result
would have been catastrophic hmm
my view is that the North that the North
American continent has gotten along fine
with two Anglo American Republic's if it
had been three or more history would
have been different but would have been
what it wouldn't have been catastrophic
Lee different and and speaking of the
example of Canada
you know when Canada was looking at the
at this accession of the peaceful
secession of Quebec its population was
about the same size as the Union at the
time and the population of Quebec was
greater than
the Gulf Coast Confederacy that
initially seceded and slightly less than
the Confederacy once Lincoln had called
out troops did Lincoln have any advisors
or anyone close to him at the time that
was just saying forget this you know
just let them go no we're gonna do it
live by our laws here so he really yeah
well there were some there were some
newspaper editors prior to Fort Sumter
who were in favor of a peaceful
secession and letting the south at least
temporarily go in peace there was even a
secessionist movement in New York City
but meaning they wanted New York City
this is yeah yeah even though
graphically and Lincoln's Secretary of
State toyed with the idea of provoking a
war with Great Britain in order to bring
everybody Seward back together but but
nobody really at least within Republican
councils accepted once especially after
Fort Sumter the preservation of the
Union becomes uppermost yeah so most of
his presidency which obviously was cut
short and I'll get to them shortly was
it was about the Civil War right is
there what else we have to know how it's
sort of towards the end of the war what
other decisions did he make that were
sort of pivotal well he starts a
reconstruction program which is
relatively lenient compared to the
Congressional reconstruction that is
eventually implemented after Lincoln's
assassination I mean even in what regard
lenient in terms of allowing white
Southerners
a free hand in terms of as long as they
about had abolish slavery of re-entering
the union and how was that different
than what happened well basically well
this is a complicated story I'm going to
try to make it really simple okay you
have this first phase presidential
reconstruction which in Lincoln
initiates and then becomes really
lenient under his successor Andrew
Johnson who was from Tennessee a very
racist but anti-slavery southerner and
what happens is that the southern states
essentially set up under a lot of the
former Confederate leadership an
apartheid regime with black codes that
are very restrictive on on the
activities of the freed
african-americans and this outrages
northern Republicans and so you have a
period of congressional reconstruction
where none of these governments are
they're all disbanded you have military
occupation and then you have the
creation of new Republican governments
in which a lot of southerners are
disfranchised and african-americans are
given voting rights and so you have a
period of Republican regimes in the
south and then that creates the
resistance of organizations like the Ku
Klux Klan and other violent
organizations and by 1876 northerners
have gotten tired of trying to maintain
these regimes with military occupation
and so you have what's euphemistically
referred to as Redemption where you have
the restoration of a white rule
throughout the former slave states yeah
so it's just hard to imagine what a
messy time it would have been yeah
during those years just healing all
those wounds literally family members
having killed each other right yeah
especially in your border states like
Kentucky and Missouri yeah I mean it's
really just hard to imagine what it was
like so the North obviously wins this
act does not secede the Union is
maintained what was happening just in
the weeks leading up to his
assassination well Lee surrendered same
month I believe and so it was clear that
it's it's it's clear that the that the
Confederacy has lost the war and you
have the passage of the 13th amendment
by Congress it still has to be ratified
by the states abolishing slavery and
those are the most the two most
important events leading up to the yeah
at the end of the war so to talk about
the assassination for a little bit I
mean obviously just from everything
we're talking about it and it was
wartime and everything else that
obviously you know tensions were high
and all that was there any reason to
believe that anything like this was
gonna happen I know that may sound like
a it's a very open question but you know
like were there attempted assassination
attempts before that anything whether
there was always concern about Lincoln
being assassinated particularly at the
outset of the war I mean pardon me at
the outset of his administration so when
he initially comes into Washington he
comes in disguised because of concern
about an assassination of rumored
assassination attempts and then during
the inauguration you have sharpshooters
stationed at the tops of buildings and
and other provisions made by General
Winfield Scott to make sure that there
is no assassination attempt because
remember Washington DC
is south of Maryland Maryland is a slave
state it's a safe state that doesn't
secede only partially because of Union
military force interfering with
elections and throwing secessionists in
jail and Baltimore is at least at the
outset of the war is a pro-southern
hotbed so there were always concerns
yeah but we don't have the Secret
Service in fact the Secret Service is
created during the Civil War mainly to
track down counterfeiters
it's one of the many government agencies
that we've come to all love right
emerges during the Civil War
Wow that's why it started to track down
counterfeiters yeah now it's clearly
gone beyond that scope these days but
that that's a whole other topic so I
assume that the day I mean if we had to
look at Lincoln the morning he woke up
before he went to the theater he had to
have been feeling pretty good about
things I mean he had he has accomplished
the the thing that was most important to
him right he certainly was feeling
relieved yeah what should we talk about
related to the assassination well give
me the basics for people that well well
I I don't I mean there's now evidence
that there was more involvement of
Confederate counterintelligence whatever
you want to call it then we previously
in other words it wasn't entirely John
Wilkes Booth and and his confederates
they're hard evidence on that yeah yeah
and but I don't really have a lot to say
about about the assassination of Lincoln
insofar as okay here one of the big
debates is if Lincoln hadn't been
assassinated
would he have continued his lenient
policy towards
the southern states and and I go along
with the historians who say no that he
was trying leniency in order to try to
reestablish the Whig party in the south
but it wasn't turning out that way and
congressional reconstruction may not
have been quite as harsh under lincoln
as it turned out to be without Lincoln
but but Lincoln's views had evolved to
the extent that he would not have been
would have been willing to tolerate the
Black Codes that that the states were
setting up do you think certainly by his
second term where he would have had a
freer hand he would have done a lot of
the things that would that happen during
congressional reconstruction yeah that's
my speculation yeah what was it like
after the assassination well it's like
any assassination you know there there
there is a manhunt there is an attempt
to track down the conspiracy and you
have several conspirators hung including
Mary Surratt who's and there's a lot of
controversy about whether she was
actually involved or not involved and so
it certainly hardens northern attitudes
but remember was there really a feeling
that he was the one keeping it all
together at that point still or what was
the feeling that the war had been won it
was it was going to be okay either way
you know he was such a symbol of what
had happened I mean he he had all room
that's an interesting question
in some circles
he had already become deified but not to
the extent that the assassination
deified
so he remember he'd already been elected
for a second term
so so he did not face significant
political opposition he their what their
before the fall of Atlanta there were
they're there because the war dragged on
so long it wasn't always clear that
Lincoln would be ranana nated by the
Republican Party and there were elements
in the Republican Party who wanted to
replace him and rivals who wanted to
replace him so really you have you have
Andrew Johnson being president you know
for most of Lincoln's second term and
he's impeached or Omaha
he's impeached and almost removed from
office because of this disagreement with
the Republicans who are in tight control
of Congress because the southern states
have been kept out are still not in
except for Tennessee and the slave
states that didn't secede there they're
still not in the Union I are permitted
to have representatives in Congress so
the Republicans have a free hand
irrespective of whether Lincoln's in
office or Andrew Johnson's in office or
our grant is in office all right
interesting so one of the reasons that I
wanted to do this YouTube week was to
help frame things around how politics
are right now so to sort of wrap all
this up first what what do you think
Lincoln's politics would be today if you
were to try to take the things that you
think he believed in the most within a
sort of modern context is there a way
that you can make sense of it because I
see he gets used by everyone all the
time Lincoln would have been a
Republican for this he would have been a
Democrat for this is there where I don't
like I don't like playing that game yeah
I mean things have changed so much
it's really and the context is so
different it's really hard to say one of
the one of the interesting things about
Lincoln and this is one of my what am I
sort of reservations our criticisms of
Lincoln actually criticisms of the
people who defy Lincoln as president is
the Whig party had this ambivalent
attitude in terms of government versus
the presidency they were in favor of a
lot of government intervention but at
the same time they had emerged in
opposition to Andrew Jackson and his
very vigorous often high-handed
presidency so they tended to favor the
legislature as the dominant mover force
in the government rather than the
presidency and I think Lincoln had
imbibed this wig attitude about
administration and as a result I think
being a wartime president he had to
ignore it to a large extent but I think
that it created some of the
administrative problems that emerged
during Lincoln's presidency so I think
Lincoln would be would have very
ambivalent feelings about how powerful
the president has become within
government irrespective of what policies
were being implemented
I will accept I will accept that as an
answer that that really was what I'm
trying to get to not that he would have
been doing this policy or that Posse but
just his general take on what power was
the opposite of the presidency and and
things of that nature well it's been a
pleasure talking to you are we done
we're done we did the whole hour we do
we miss anything man there's a lot of
major things all right give me something
major
well I I'll give you a couple things one
is I mean my book
you didn't mention my book let's talk
about well I think you sort of hit on it
there you're more critical my more
critical elfman in the war then right
get people who do fine
yeah the book is a narrative history of
the Civil War but I have about half a
dozen provocative theses where I
disagree with / ailing views and one of
them is that I argue that if northerners
had been interested in ending slavery
rather than preserving the Union there
is a set of policies they could have
adopted allowing the lower South to go
in peace which would have brought down
slavery within an independent
Confederacy certainly by the turn of the
century and possibly within four years
and why letting them go would do that
well letting them go didn't necessarily
do it it just means that you didn't have
to kill 750,000 people in order to bring
about the end of slavery right in other
words I think there were there is a pot
there's a they're a set of policies that
it could have achieved the same goal at
less cost and and in other words I think
you can like the out I was actually
turned tuned on turned on to this
alternative by garrison and the other
radical abolitionists in other words you
can be rapidly anti-slavery and still
Pro secession mmm-hmm the second
important argument I make is has to do
with the growth of government I think
it's a commonplace observation the
government today is a lot more powerful
and a lot more intrusive than it was
earlier in our history and whether you
think that's a good thing or a bad thing
there's the question of what changed and
what brought about the change so the
popular story is that it's the New Deal
right that made the big change and
and in the growth of government and I
think that's mistaken
it's mistaken in part because the New
Deal was essentially a recreation of
Woodrow Wilson's War collectivism and
the impact of the New Deal on government
was dwarfed by the impact of World War
two now there's some elements of truth
the New Deal gives you social security
and along with Medicare that's become
government's biggest expenditures more
sophisticated commentators would push
the change back to the Progressive Era
in the early 20th century but I'm
arguing that the Civil War is the
crucial watershed in American history
that prior to that prior to the Civil
War the long-term secular trend had at
all levels of government for government
to become smaller less intrusive less
involved in people's lives and that the
turning point is the Civil War hmm that
leaves him with a complex legacy from
yes government yes yes yeah interesting
yeah because during the Civil War I mean
national conscription the u.s. moves
from free trade to high protective
tariffs the first Western country to do
so massive subsidies to railroads for
subsidies to higher education through
the land grants and I've already gone
over my time I could go on and on you
got one more one more big big point
that's in the book related to Lincoln
yeah one more point that's related to
Lincoln I think that one of the reasons
it takes the Union so long to defeat the
Confederacy is because of Lincoln's bad
administration of the military there he
tended to micromanage the war like
Lyndon Johnson tried to micromanage the
Vietnam War and historians want to place
all of the blame on Lincoln's
generals whereas I think that really the
source of the problem is Lincoln
consider the eastern theater alright so
you have a succession of commanders
Irvin McDowell defeated at the first
bull ride and replaced by McClellan
McClellan is almost supplanted by John
Pope who's defeated the second Bull Run
only to bring back McClellan then to
replace him with Burnside who admitted
to mitad that he wasn't ready to command
the army and then Hooker and then meet
right now normally right and this is
within a period of two years to two and
a half years normally this doesn't war
earn administrators high marks in terms
of how they're managing things right and
I think that I mean there were problems
with all the generals the advantage that
the generals in the West had Sherman and
grant is they weren't micro managed by
Lincoln and therefore they could make
their mistakes early in the war and
learn from them yeah well I like that
you gave us a complex view I mean that's
really why I wanted to do this that you
know we pick certain ones that Lincoln
is one that we all sort of view in this
lens of there's this perfect being yeah
the Lincoln of course and of course he
did a tremendous amount of good but it's
interesting hearing what the little
imperfections are and all sorts of
things so on that note it has been a
pleasure talking to you and for more on
Jeffery Rogers Hummel check out his book
which we're gonna link to right down
below
you
[Music]